this movie teaches us one very important
lesson folks and that is Leonardo
DiCaprio is impervious to hypothermia
please his character is in this movie
holy [ __ ] I look cold the revenant
finally
so the revenant a new movie directed by
Alejandro Gonzalez Inarritu came out in
2015 around Christmas normal folk like
me we get to watch it now this movie
takes place in the 1800s DiCaprio is out
there with a crew of people gathering
pelts their hunting game and getting
their pelts because there's big money in
that and then a big huge grizzly bear
attacks the [ __ ] out of him great Saint
I mean it's a disturbing scene but oh my
god that was just intense in the sense
that it's real looking doesn't I can say
about a lot of this movie a lot of it
looked so real you almost feel bad for
watching you for entertainment sake
you're like I feel uncomfortable because
it looks that real so he's clinging on
to life but Tom Hardy's like we should
finish him off quick
so Tom Hardy kills DiCaprio son leaves
DiCaprio for dead only thing DiCaprio
didn't die so now he is crawling through
the wilderness to come after Tom Hardy
and hopefully kill him yeah this movies
an interesting one man this is one of
the few times when I'm reviewing a movie
I want to call it a film as it to terms
to describe the same thing really but
for somebody I was watching this movie I
was like this is a film for the art of
film and in that you got to know what
you're getting into for this movie I
mean if your friend describes this
movies like oh yeah man like DiCaprio
and Tom Hardy tries to kill him but he
doesn't kill them and so DiCaprio is
coming after him it's like revenge movie
man revenge in the wilderness of the
1800s yeah that's kind of the flyby
synopsis of the movie but don't go into
this movie expecting kill bill in the
wilderness you're gonna be disappointed
you're probably gonna be bored this
isn't as much a film about revenge as it
is about man he fights the elements more
than he fights Tom Hardy in here not
only that but Ollie Haun drove Gonzales
enter it can I call him alejandro GI I'm
gonna call him that
Alejandro GI in Birdman showed us he has
an affinity for drawing out one shot as
long as possible a few shots in this
movie when the action is going down
we're talking this [ __ ] is going down
it's gritty it's real you almost feel
uncomfortable watching it for
entertainment but that shot goes on for
a while and then you hear about how we
wanted to film this movie in natural
light in the wilderness to make it legit
which means he's using the Sun I mean
this is light source in this movie so
it's like alright the Sun is perfect we
have
90 minutes to get this scene and when
you're watching it you're like if anyone
screwed this up it'd be like alright L
[ __ ] we're past it now so hey we'll
come back tomorrow try it again
I'm sure the studio hated that I'm sure
they hate that [ __ ] they're like you are
costing us money will you make it back I
hope but I just love that kind of
madness and passion in the filmmaking
world I love seeing it and it does make
a difference when you're watching this
movie or like I feel like it is the
1800s and it's cold as [ __ ] when I was
watching this movie I was sequentially
getting colder as I watched it I don't
think the theater was playing a prank on
me I don't think they were turning the
a/c up it was the effect the movie had
on me because the director was able to
put you in there and a couple of the
scraps man the scraps in this movie like
the fights they were dirty boy when two
people are fighting in this movie I
might need your curry action was to jump
in there be like God got fellas fellas
come on you're gonna kill each other
stop and yeah the performances were all
great they were all fantastic I mean
Leonardo DiCaprio going for the Oscar
again probably gonna get nominated is he
gonna win I have no idea he shouldn't
want an Oscar a few times at this point
it doesn't matter a trophy doesn't
actually matter the performances he's
been giving us in his movies that
matters and I always look forward to a
new DiCaprio movie because I know no
matter what trophy he does or does not
take home he has always earned it but I
mean Tom Hardy was great domhnall
gleeson was great that kid from the Maze
Runner sergeant eyebrows hold on will
Poulter I had to look that up because he
deserves to have his name said because
he was quite good the movie he added his
fair share to this movie so good job
dude in the end the revenant is not the
exciting revenge tale some people might
want it to be but it's the most
realistic revenge tale that I have seen
in quite a long time possibly ever
I love the directors flair for this
gritty realism I loved the fact that he
wanted to film with natural light I
loved how this movie pulls you into it
you genuinely feel like you are in this
time period if you're looking for that
high-octane exciting revenge tale not
here but if you genuinely appreciate the
art of cinema and that's your thing
you're gonna love this one I will say
the revenant is definitely worth
watching and worth buying on blu-ray
soon I'm gonna have to change that to
digital we're downloading digitally
alright guys so the revenant have you
seen it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more